Tim Ferriss: Hello, boys and girls, ladies
and germs. This is Tim Ferriss. Welcome to
another episode of The Tim Ferriss Show, where
it is always my job to deconstruct world-class
performers, to interview people who are very good
at what they do, to find out what makes them tick,
their influences, things you can use, that you
can borrow from their life, from their lived
experience. And my guest today is David Eagleman.
You can find him on Twitter @DavidEagleman,
Eagle Man, just as you would think it's
spelled. And David is a neuroscientist,
New York Times bestselling author, TED speaker,
and Guggenheim Fellow. We're going to come back to
the Guggenheim Fellow, I think, very shortly. He
is the writer and presenter of the Emmy-nominated
series The Brain on PBS, as well as the podcast
Inner Cosmos with David Eagleman. In Palo Alto,
California, he teaches at Stanford University,
you may have heard of it. Runs a startup neurotech
company called Neosensory and directs the Center
for Science and Law. Dr. Eagleman also runs a film
and television production company, Cognito
Entertainment, to bring scientific themes,
fiction, and non-fiction to the screen. And in
his spare time, he is the author of eight books,
including the international bestsellers Sum,
Incognito — I learn. I learn — and his newest
book, Livewired. You can find all things David
at eagleman.com. David, it’s so nice to finally
carve out the time to have this conversation.
David Eagleman: Great. Great to be here, Tim.
Tim Ferriss: And I thought we would start
with a topic while near and dear to my heart,
it's not something I know that much about and that
is synesthesia. And I'll preface that by saying
one book that I found somehow, I don't know
how, in high school, which later led to me for
a very brief stint being a neuroscience major or
a psychology major with a focus on neuroscience,
was a book by A.R. Luria. And I may screw
up another word here, but The Mind of a —
David Eagleman: Mnemonist.
Tim Ferriss: Mnemonist. I always
want to say Nemonist, but like mnemonic device,
Mnemosyne, the Greek goddess of memory. So that
gave me insight as any reader of this book would
find into a vast memory and what maybe hypermnesia
or incredibly unusual performance in that arena
can look like. Would you mind just taking a moment
to define synesthesia and to then describe the
work that you've done in that area or aspects
of it that you find particularly interesting?
David Eagleman: So a mnemonist is someone who
can memorize anything in their life, as you know
from the book, giant list of arbitrary numbers or
things like that. Some people have this ability
and it turns out, as far as I can tell anyway,
that every single one of these people has
synesthesia. So synesthesia is where there's
an association between some stimulus and something
else. So for example, numbers triggering a color
experience. So three is purple, nine is yellow,
and so on. But it's not only colors, it can be
other things like gender and personality and shape
and size and things like that. So for someone who
has synesthesia, when they're memorizing,
let's say the digits of Pi, there's a whole
story landscape going on where the small yellow
girl who is number three is talking to the angry
boy who's number seven, and then who's talking
to the old woman who's number nine and so on.
There's a whole story there, and that's how
mnemonists tend to memorize their stuff. But
synesthesia, it turns out, is quite common.
It's about three percent of the population has
some form of synesthesia. And the thing
I've always found fascinating about it,
the reason I've studied it for about 20 years
now, is because it is just an example of how
reality can be different in your head and in
my head. And we would both accept it as okay,
that's how the world is. I should just mention
there are all these forms of synesthesia like
hearing might lead to a taste in your mouth
or tasting something might lead to a feeling
on your fingertips or a loud sound might cause
you to see something or whatever. It's just any
blending of the senses, we call that synesthesia.
Tim Ferriss: All right. Many follow up questions
because I've never had a conversation
with someone who has spent the amount of
time looking at synesthesia as you have. So two
immediate questions come to mind. So mnemonist,
would you say that that label applies
to only those who seem to organically
have these abilities and maybe the presence of
synesthesia? Or does it also apply to people
who develop or learn techniques for, say,
competing in memory competitions? Because
they can do things that are seemingly
beyond the reach of the average human,
but they're not Kim Peek reading two books at the
same time, one eye on each page, let's just say.
David Eagleman: So like with
many things, there's congenital,
which means you're born with it or acquired, which
means you get it some other way. So for example,
there's congenital synesthesia where you're born
with this mixture of the senses, but acquired is
when people take certain psychedelic drugs
and they listen to music and it cause them
to see colors and shapes, that sort of thing.
So yes, you could be a mnemonist that acquires
your skills through hard training, and usually
that training involves just tapping into other
modalities like we're really good at location.
All animals really care a lot about locations.
So you know all the stuff about memory palaces
and whatever. And you're memorizing a sequence
by placing things in your mind in different
locations in your house, let's say. So that's
the way that somebody trains is by tapping in.
And really that's what synesthesia is about,
is neighboring areas of the brain that are sort of
tied together more than you would normally expect.
So for somebody who has colored numbers,
normally we memorize the numbers or the
weekdays or the months or whatever thing we're
forced to arbitrarily memorize as a child
for a synesthete, they tie it into something like
colors or in many cases, spatial location. So many
synesthetes have, let's say the months of the
year are laid out in front of them. So they say,
oh, March is over here and April's kind of up
and to the right of it. And then May is down
here and June, July and it usually circles
around their body, that kind of thing. But
they have a very spatial sense of the months or
the years or the number line, things like that.
Tim Ferriss: So we may come back to that, but I
would like to jump to something that I think is
certainly adjacent and that is creating new senses
in some respects, and this makes me think of
one of your probably several TED talks, but can we
create new senses for humans? I saw this quite a
long time ago. I put it in my newsletter 5-Bullet
Friday, because I thought it was very much worth
watching and considering, not just considering
what you had then, but the implications of
developing technology. So would you mind
describing outside of congenital synesthesia,
outside of gobbling psilocybe mushrooms and
seeing the Andromeda Galaxy appear before you
as you hear Pink Floyd, there are other options
for developing a new ability or new faculty to
perceive the world. So would you mind speaking to
sensory addition, if that's the right term to use?
David Eagleman: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: And maybe
we start with recent progress.
David Eagleman: The whole thing
that got me interested in this a while ago was
understanding, just really thinking about the fact
that the brain is locked in silence and darkness
inside the skull. And all it ever sees are these
little electrical signals, which also can cause
chemical release and so on. But you've just got
these electrochemical signals running around in
the dark, and yet when you open your eyes and look
at the world, you see everything in full color
and it looks so rich and so on, and you're hearing
music and you're feeling things on your fingertips
and you're smelling cinnamon. And all these things
seem like very distinct senses to you, but
they're all made of exactly the same stuff,
which is these electrochemical spikes. And so
I got really interested in this idea of could
we feed information into the brain via an unusual
source, and would the brain just figure it out?
And so what we did is we built a vest that had
vibratory motors on it, and this was for people
who were deaf. It can capture sound and turn
the sound into patterns of vibration on the
skin from high to low frequency, which is exactly
what the inner ear does. And we put it on deaf
people and train them. And it turns out that works
great. You can learn to hear through your skin.
And it's because essentially the brain doesn't
care how the information gets there as long as
it gets there somehow, the brain will figure
out what to do with it. And the way it does
is by making correlations with other senses.
So you see the dog's mouth move and you feel
the barking on your skin and your brain figures
out, oh, that's the sound that goes with that.
And so I gave that TED Talk on it where I showed
the vest, and then in the interim, what I did from
that time is I shrunk it down to a wristband.
I actually spun a company off, so I should say
we shrunk it down because the whole company was
involved in this very hard work, shrunk it down
to a wristband, and we're on wrists all over
the world. And that's not only for deafness,
but also for tinnitus, ringing in the ears. I
can explain how that works if interesting, but
also for age-related hearing loss. So as people
get older, they lose their high frequencies.
So we just use machine learning on this wristband
that listens in real time for the high frequency
parts of speech like a TH or an S or a V or
a B, and it buzzes your wrist in different
ways to let you know, Hey, I just heard a TH,
I heard A, B, a V. And so what happens is your
ear is doing all the work at the medium and low
frequencies and the wristband is just clarifying
what just got said at the high frequency.
And turns out that works like gangbusters.
Your brain can learn to fuse those signals quite
easily, and after a few weeks people, they don't
need hearing aids. It replaces a hearing aid.
Tim Ferriss: So your mind fills in the blanks once
you develop the ability to associate properly.
David Eagleman: Exactly, because your mind is
getting the information now through your
wrist, through the skin of your wrist,
which is essentially acting like a perfect inner
ear. We're just transferring the inner ear to the
skin essentially. And that just passes the
information into the brain. The brain says,
"Oh, I got it. That was sheep versus sheet versus
sheik," just figures out, it gets the information
from the wrist and puts it all together.
Tim Ferriss: So for the wrists to work
like the vest did, what was the most important
technological innovation? Because I think of
the surface area of the vest, I'm like, okay,
your ability to discern, say, vibration of the
chest versus the back would be fairly, it would
appear to be fairly straightforward, but once you
constrain that to surface area and contact on the
wrist, I would imagine that probably incorrectly,
but I would imagine that to be much more difficult
for the user to parse and learn to decipher.
David Eagleman: It's actually not
because you have very low spatial
resolution on your torso. In other words —
Tim Ferriss: Right. It's the density.
David Eagleman: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
David Eagleman: So you have higher on the wrist,
but your intuition is right that there's just
less room on the wrist to stick motors. So we have
fewer motors than we had on the vest. It turns out
we use an illusion, which is if I stimulate
two neighboring motors, you will feel one
virtual point in between those two motors.
Tim Ferriss: It's like binaural beats with audio.
David Eagleman: Yeah, exactly. And as I
change the amplitude of those two motors,
I can move that virtual point around. So
we're actually stimulating 128 virtual
points on the wrist is what we're doing.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, that's clever. You clever
bastards. Good for you. So I wanted to
ask about maybe not replacement therapy
in the sense of hearing, say hearing
loss, fixing hearing loss, or fixing a
pathology, I think that would be fair to say
with tinnitus or tinnitus, which I happen to
have. So I'd be curious to know how that works.
It's not very pervasive in my lived experience,
but it does happen. I'd love to know also,
so this is a very sloppy compound question,
you can choose as you would at a
buffet where you'd like to go with it.
What might exist for healthy normals in
terms of augmenting the scope of their
sensory experience? I don't expect it will all
become manta shrimp or something like that.
But I'll mention a name that people might
want to look up. Ed Cooke, and I don't know
if you know this name, but he trained the author
behind a book called Moonwalking with Einstein
to win the National Memory Championships
in the United States. Ed himself, very,
very high level memory competitor, also fascinated
with sensory substitution and sensory addition.
So maybe we could start with the tinnitus
or tinnitus and then go from there to what
do you think the applications are or could
be for healthy normals, if that makes sense.
David Eagleman: Terrific. Okay.
So first thing by the way is that
everyone calls it tinnitus and audiologists
call it tinnitus and either one is correct, so.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, great.
David Eagleman: Second thing is
the way it works is something that is so simple,
it's called bimodal stimulation, but all it is,
is we're playing tones, boo, boo, boo, boo, boo,
boo, around your tinnitus frequency, and you're
feeling the corresponding buzzes on your skin. So
you're hearing the sound in your ears and you're
feeling the buzz on your skin. That drives down
the tinnitus as much as any solution that exists.
The reason it works, there are very complicated
arguments, but I think the simple thing is that
you're teaching the brain what is a real external
sound because the skin is giving you verification
that the sound actually is real.
Tim Ferriss: It is external.
David Eagleman: Yeah, exactly. As opposed to
the beep on the inside, which is fake news.
Tim Ferriss: Or I guess originating externally.
David Eagleman: Yeah, exactly. Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
David Eagleman: But the stuff on the
inside isn't real and it doesn't get verification
or confirmation on the wrist. And so your brain
figures out, oh, okay, I don't need to pay as
much attention to that. So that's how that works,
which is cool. Now your question. Okay. So
that, great. So we're doing all these things
in the hearing space, and that's actually what my
company Neosensory is on the market with because
that's all a very direct path. But the really
interesting thing is we've got 70 projects,
seven zero different projects about sensory
addition and sensory expansion. And so some of
my favorites are things like for a long time I've
been wearing infrared light just so I can pick up
on what's going on in the infrared range. And you
can actually do this in the near infrared or the
mid-wave infrared. But in the near infrared, the
first time I put it on, I happened to be walking
at nighttime in between a couple houses and I
suddenly felt all this infrared radiation, but
I couldn't figure out where it was coming from.
So I just followed my wrist and there was a
security camera with infrared LEDs, which normally
is totally invisible to you, you can't see that.
But it was so obvious to me that the security
camera was there because I could feel it. But in
the mid-range, that's when it's really interesting
because that's the temperature, that's where it's
picking up heat signatures. And so I can walk
through the parking lot and know immediately which
cars have been parked there a while and which ones
have just pulled up in the last half hour because
there's a lot of heat coming from the engine
block. I can just feel that. Or when I happened
to go in the library the first time I was wearing
this, and I could tell there were two empty
chairs, I could tell which one was sat in at some
point in the last half hour because there's still
a heat signature there. And even the books on the
display where people have recently picked up a
book, they still leave the heat signature there.
So it's really amazing. It's like slicing up time
in a different way when you're tapped into the
infrared range. But we have all kinds of projects
where you can feed in data from the internet,
stock market data, Twitter data. One of the cool
things that we did is we took one of these smart
watches that can pick up on your gathering skin
response and heart rate and heart rate variability
and that stuff. And then we, using the API,
we fed that data out and over the internet and
then to the wristband. So you can feel all that.
But the interesting part is when you take the
wristband off and put it on someone else. So let's
say your spouse is tapped into your physiology
and your spouse can feel the things that you're —
Tim Ferriss: Time to leave
Tim alone. He's dysregulated.
David Eagleman: Exactly. I have
really no idea if this is a
useful thing for marriages, but it is totally
cool to be able to know when someone else is
feeling stressed out. I mean, you can be, the
reason we did this over the internet is you
can be on the other side of the globe and you
can suddenly call your wife and say, "Hey baby,
you stressed out? You're feeling okay?" And
anyway, it's just a really interesting thing.
So we're exploring lots of things. None of
them have clear market paths, but they're
the thing that feeds me scientifically.
Tim Ferriss: Of the 70 experiments/projects
that you have running, why did you
choose the infrared for yourself?
David Eagleman: Oh, because several of
them are clinical. They have to do it,
let's say for example, for prosthetic legs
or peripheral neuropathies or whatever,
we're just feeding data in. But because
I don't have any of those problems,
not yet, knock on wood, it turns out that I'm
into the idea of sensory expansion. Can I tap
into other things? And one of the things as maybe
you remember from my TED Talk, one of the things
I've always been fascinated by is how little we
see of the world. We see such a tiny fraction of
what is happening out there. So I've always wanted
to be tapped into a lot more. Just as an example,
you may remember this from the TED talk, the
amount what we call visible light, the ROYGBIV,
that's less than a 10 trillionth of the light
that's out there of the electromagnetic spectrum.
And so it turns out that all these other things,
x-rays, microwaves, and gamma rays and all these
things are passing through your body totally
invisible to you because you don't have the
proper receptors to pick up on it. But I suspect
there are a whole bunch of Nobel Prizes hidden
out there in different parts of the spectrum if
we could just pick up on those and detect them
in our daily lives and be aware of things. And
by the way, I should clarify one thing on that.
We have all kinds of ways of detecting things
in the spectrum in those different parts, but
only in the laboratory. We're not walking
around and experiencing the world that way.
And I think that's what makes all the difference.
I'll just give you one example, just to clarify
what I'm saying. Some colleagues of mine have this
company where they look in the microwave range at
the oceans to see where the ships are going, and
they can make estimates of commerce that way and
so on. But what they discovered quite accidentally
is that if you look at water in the microwave
range, you can tell if it's drinkable or not.
You can tell what water's drinkable and what's
not. And nobody knew that before. It's just one
of these things where you have to look and say,
"Oh, hey, did you notice this?" And so that's what
I think we are set up for is so many discoveries
of just being in the world in different,
having different types of vision on the world.
Tim Ferriss: If you had to maybe edge
into the realm of science fiction, but
informed science fiction, could just be informed
projection, let's say in the next five years,
what would be your wildest hopes or dreams
for the future of this type of technology?
David Eagleman: One of them is that I think we
can really use AI and machine learning for a lot
of very useful stuff. I'll give you one example
of actually a company that's spun off from our
company, which is it's these three college
students who are doing this awesome thing to
help people with autism understand the social
context that they're in. So kids with autism
usually can't tell if the person they're talking
to is angry or happy or sad or whatever. So the
wristband just uses machine learning to listen
and say, oh, that person is angry or happy or sad
or whatever, and then just buzzes to tell you the
right answer. And this kind of thing is so useful.
Obviously we are in the middle of this explosion
of what's going on in AI. And to be able to use
that and do some very sophisticated thing and
then just feed the data back into the user and
just tell the user the simple answer to the very
complicated thing going on out there, I think,
we're just going to see so much of that happening.
Tim Ferriss: Are there any other applications
that come to mind? And it doesn't have to
be human centric. It could be something
like the augmentation you described with
microwave range and the potability of water.
But do any other applications come to mind?
David Eagleman: One that we proposed a long
time ago and we sort of did a tiny bit
of work on is about stock market data,
summarizing what's happening in the stock market
and moment to moment, you can feel it on your skin
or there are many ways to do it, with whole
patterns or just like, hey, I want to follow
Google and Meta and whatever. And you can feel
what's going on. And what I'm interested in
is if we train someone for the long term on
this, can they get to the point where they say,
"Hey, I just have this feeling, this gut feeling
that oil is crashing right now," or something,
without even being perceptually aware of what all
these signals are and what they mean. Can they
just develop a direct perceptual experience
of the economic movements of the planet.
Tim Ferriss: Just developing trading intuitives.
David Eagleman: Yeah. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: By feeding
them lots and lots of data.
David Eagleman: Because that's all
vision and hearing and all this stuff is.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
David Eagleman: We experience
lots of data. When you're a kid, when you're a
baby, you don't know how the heck to use your
eyes or ears or whatever. You're just getting all
this data going into the darkness there and you
figure stuff out. You figure out correlations.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Well, it also ties in,
and I suspect we won't go too deeply on this, but
relates to AI and also just technology in general,
machine learning as well, because
it turns out some of the things
we might have assumed to be very, very
complex like playing chess, playing go,
are very easy to train machines for.
David Eagleman: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Whereas if you want a machine
to catch a ball, if you want a machine to
walk in some capacity, do things that we take
for granted, drive a car, some of the simplest
things turn out to be the hardest things. And it
seems to be that underscores in a way how unaware
most of us are of how much we are processing
at any given point in time. It's remarkable.
David Eagleman: Yeah. This, by the way, is why I
wrote my book Incognito some years ago, which is
about everything that's running under the hood
that we don't have access to. I mean, the amount
that your conscious mind has access to, it's
the broom closet in the mansion of the brain,
the part where you say, oh yeah,
I'm aware of this. I mean, look,
I'm raising this cup of water to my mouth. I have
no idea how I'm doing the thing with my arm and
my elbow and I'm getting into my mouth. All I am
aware of is whether I spilled it on myself or not.
And it's like that with everything in your life,
getting a joke, falling in love, driving a car,
all this stuff is happening totally unconsciously.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. How do you think these days,
this is going to be a bit of a broad question,
there's probably a better way to put it, but about
memory and specifically the reason behind the
question or recall — let me make it more specific
— is that we learn, we forget or we use these
terms in ways that imply we know what those mean.
And I've had experiences where, say, I studied
language long ago, 10, 15, 20 years ago. At the
time I was pretty decent, but if you were to put
me in circumstances that require German right now,
I would not be able to perform. But in certain
states, whether that's in, say, a non-ordinary
state of consciousness induced by psychedelic
compounds or others, it's not the only one
in periods of say, very deep ketosis where
I'm doing, say, an extended fast and I have
2.53 millimolars of BHB measured by finger prick.
I do then appear to have access to these memories
I had assumed I had "forgotten" in quotation
marks. How do you think about these things?
David Eagleman: First of all, I'd love to do
actual test with you on the, like what I mean is,
for example, we could just pull up online
some basic German test where you're doing
something and see whether, when in deep
ketosis, if you have a better score —
Tim Ferriss: Sure.
David Eagleman: — than you do otherwise.
Tim Ferriss: To verify it. For sure.
David Eagleman: Yeah. Because if that is
verifiable, that's amazing and cool. And what
it illustrates is something that we do know,
which is that that stuff is in there. And we
know this for several reasons. I mean, big one is
if somebody says a German word, let's say that
you haven't heard in years, but you say, "Oh yeah,
that's right. I remember that word." I mean, all
that stuff's in there. The other thing is there's
a psychological effect called savings, which is,
let's say you've studied German for a long time,
then you don't study it for years, but then you
pick it up again and you say, okay, I'm going to
get really serious and study this. You'll be much
faster at learning it because all that data's in
there, or in some form, it's in there. And so
it's much, much faster the second time around.
Just as an example, when astronauts come back
from orbit, they have to relearn how to walk,
but it doesn't take them as long as it does an
infant. They're first, they can't really walk
on their own, and then they're walking fine. So
yeah. What is fascinating, and maybe this is part
of what you were getting at with your question,
is we use the word memory in computers, and that's
such a shame that we use the same word because
there's hardly any relationship there. Memory in
a computer is perfect. You're putting in zeros and
ones. You get those same zeros and ones back out.
In a human brain, it's a totally different thing
going on. And in my last book, Livewired, I talk
about how memory actually has to get moved around
in the brain and moved into different states,
and there's all kinds of weird stuff.
Here I'll just, I'll flag one or two, which
is one of them is that memory actually has to be
reconsolidated after you take it out of long-term
storage. So maybe you knew this, but so let's say
to a listener, if I ask you, "What's the name of
your fifth grade teacher?" You haven't thought
about that presumably in a very long time. So you
bring that out of cold storage, let's call it, and
you're thinking about it now. Now it's an active
memory represented by spikes running around in
the brain. If you get hit in the head right now,
that'll be gone. It'll be gone. Or if I
give you a protein synthesis inhibitor —
Tim Ferriss: Meaning that you've brought
it to the bullpen, so to speak, but now
it's vulnerable to interruption in such a way
that it would not make its way back to cold
storage. Is that what you mean?
David Eagleman: That's exactly
right. That's exactly right.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
David Eagleman: Because the memory needs to be —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Did not realize that.
David Eagleman: Yeah, a memory needs to be
reconsolidated. It needs to be taken from
activity back into the structure of the system.
And so it's vulnerable to erasure. Super weird,
but I'll just as a side note, scary memories, very
emotionally charged memories, are not erasable.
Those are unerasable, which sucks actually,
because those are the ones that trauma victims
often want to erase. But you have what amounts to
a secondary memory system that says, "Hold on to
that, because that's the really important stuff."
Tim Ferriss: Are there any researchers
who come to mind, could be thinkers, writers,
who are doing a really interesting job of just
examining the question of what, if anything,
gets permanently deleted to come back to the
human versus computer? Because I've been
shocked how things can surface from the
recesses of my mind that I assumed had long been
sent to the landfill. There's let's just say,
this active working memory, then you have the
cold storage, long term. And I assumed okay,
at some point, the warehouse is full. Things
get taken to the landfill. But lo and behold,
certainly recognition is easier, but at points,
I've also had the recall. Is there any particular
researcher or any resources or institutes
who are looking at this in interesting ways?
David Eagleman: That's an interesting
question. That's a very tough question
to address. It's something that we
make observations on in our own lives.
Tim Ferriss: How would you test it?
David Eagleman: That's a particularly
challenging one. But people are doing all
kinds — one of the things that people do test,
which is slightly different than what you're
asking, but it's about the way that memory —
even though we believe the part that we do
remember is accurate, it's the way that drifts and
the way that memory is not so accurate.
Just as an example, my colleague Liz Phelps,
at NYU, right after September 11, 2001, she went
and interviewed a bunch of people and said, "What
exactly did you see on September 11th?" And she
was also clever enough to ask them, "Tell me your
memories from September 10th," the day before.
And they said, "Okay, well I ate lunch here. I did
this," whatever. Okay. Then she found these same
people a year later and asked them, and it turns
out both the highly emotional charged memories and
the boring memories had both drifted. It turns out
that everything drifts. Even things that you think
you could never get wrong, people get wrong all
the time. So memory is a myth-making machine, and
we're constantly reinventing our past, especially
as we tell the stories over and over again.
Tim Ferriss: Totally. This is
part of why I'm very skeptical of certain, say,
studies involving nutrition that are observational
studies where they rely on self-reporting, but
people are filling in the diary of what they ate
asynchronously. And I'm like, oh, man. I would bet
people are going to be 20 percent off minimum on
average with that type of reconstruction.
David Eagleman: That doesn't even include
the purposeful lying that people do on that.
Tim Ferriss: Right. Right. Right, exactly. So
let's shift maybe back in time a bit. I know
we've been talking about a number of the books,
and I'm going to come back to Livewired,
but I wanted to ask you about influences.
And maybe we could start with one
who some folks will recognize. But
Francis Crick, how did you meet Francis Crick?
David Eagleman: I did my post-doctoral fellowship
at a place called the Salk Institute,
and that's where Francis Crick was. And
for anyone who doesn't know, he was the
co-discoverer of the structure of DNA
and just figured out all these massively
important things in molecular biology.
He was essentially the titan of the 20th
century in biology. And I, like many people,
I think had assumed he had already passed
away or something. I didn't realize he was
still trucking along. But the thing that was so
special about that guy was that he didn't have
any of the constraints that other scientists did.
So other scientists all have to whatever. We write
grants. We write papers. We have to do mentoring
grad students, whatever, reading applications.
But because he won his Nobel Prize when he was
young, he just didn't have any of that. And as
a result, he was able to just spend a 100 percent
of his time doing deep thinking, and that was it.
I walked into his office, he had a stack of
all the journals there, Science, and Nature,
and Journal of Neuroscience, and so on. And he
was flipping through it and one day I asked him,
I said, "What are you looking for?" Because it
looked like he was looking for something. He said,
"I don't know. I'm just looking." And so anyway,
he was an amazing guy, precisely because he was
so high-IQ, so high-octane, and had no other
constraints on him. I've never known anyone
who happened to be in that position before.
Tim Ferriss: So when you mentioned the 70
projects, which I understand is within the context
of a for-profit company, so it would make sense to
examine a lot of things. But if I just look
at your bio, I see many different projects,
many different irons in the fire, and I'm looking
at an older New Yorker piece. This is from 2011,
and as it relates to Crick who died in 2004. So
the advice, and you can't believe everything you
read, but I'd love to hear you maybe expand
on this or speak to how it impacted you,
is, "The dangerous man," this is quoting Crick,
"The dangerous man is one who has only one idea
because then he'll fight and die for it. The way
real science goes is that you come up with lots of
ideas and most of them will be wrong."
David Eagleman: Right.
Tim Ferriss: What impact did that have on you?
David Eagleman: Well, I think, if anything,
that just meshed with the way
I already thought about things.
Tim Ferriss: You confirmed what you wanted to do.
David Eagleman: Exactly. Hold on, let me take a
one-second tangent here, which is the worst piece
of advice I ever had was when I was in college,
there was a professor, an electrical engineering
professor of mine, and I really liked the guy.
And he said to me one day, he said, "Look,
Eagleman, life is like you're a lumberjack,
and you go into the forest with your ax. You've
got to pick one tree, and you just hit that tree.
If you take a whack at all the trees, you're not
going to get anywhere." And it sounded so wise
and so reasonable and so on, but it's just not
who I am. I'm just not the pick-one-tree guy,
and so I think it already meshed with —
Tim Ferriss: You're preaching to the choir here.
David Eagleman: Yeah, exactly. So when Crick said
that — and by the way, any good scientist is doing
this anyway. You have lots of hypotheses, each one
of which you think, "Wow. That's going to crack
open something big," and then you realize, "Oh,
that's totally wrong." Or you run an experiment or
whatever. So you got to have a lot of them.
MIDROLL
Tim Ferriss: So let's say
you didn't have the podcast,
which people should check out,
Inner Cosmos. David Eagleman
didn't have the production company. You didn't
have any obligations outside of science, but
you had done something, maybe it was winning a
Nobel Prize, where you had the same ability to
sit in your office, sit in your lab, and basically
do whatever you want. What types of, outside of
reading widely and having piles of things on your
desk perhaps Crick did, are there any hypotheses
or experiments that you would have at the top
of your list of things to pay attention to?
David Eagleman: Most of my career has been
defined by trying to understand how the brain
constructs reality. You've got all these spikes
running around, and the question is, how does
that make this subjective reality we have with
all its colors and sounds and tastes and smells
and so on? Why does this biological activity
in a whole bunch of cells feel like something?
That feels to me like the biggest central question
in neuroscience. But there are lots of — I
actually wrote an article, I think in 2004, 2006,
I wrote the cover article for Discover magazine,
and I called it "10 Unsolved Questions of
[the Brain]." And I define 10 questions,
and these are still equally as unsolved now
as they were way back then. And so I feel like
there's so much really rich stuff to answer.
But anyway, consciousness really sits at the
middle. And by the way, for Francis Crick,
this was one of his central questions,
maybe the central question that he devoted the end
of his life to. How do you put together 86 billion
cells and get experience, get meaning out of it?
Tim Ferriss: So let's talk about consciousness
for a second, which is such a slippery pig. I know
some folks hate talking about it because they're
like, "Ah, it's like talking about God. We might
not even be talking about the same thing. Let's
define terms." But for the moment, we can put that
aside. Although, if you have a tidy definition,
I'd love to hear it. But do you think that
consciousness is an emergent property? So at some
point these building blocks, these carbon-based
structures build up, and then we have at some
point consciousness as an emergent property, or
do you feel, and maybe there's a third answer,
that it is more fundamental than that?
David Eagleman: I don't think there's
any way to know. So just to define that for the
audience, so the second view is sometimes called
panpsychism, which is that maybe consciousness is
a fundamental quality of the cosmos and gravity or
mass or whatever. It's already there and you're
putting things together in just the right way,
and the first version is that if you put a bunch
of cells together in just the right structure,
you get self-awareness and sentience. We
don't really know, and all the data we
have is consistent with either. So the data
we have on consciousness, of course, is that
if you hurt your brain, let's say with a stroke,
or tumor, or traumatic brain injury, or whatever,
or you put molecules in drugs, your consciousness
can change in any of these circumstances. But all
that tells us is that the physical integrity
of the system is necessary for the conscious
experience. But it certainly could be either.
Tim Ferriss: What was Crick trying to solve for,
or how was he trying to examine consciousness?
And I know panpsychism has developed a bit of a,
I don't want to say negative connotation, but
even some physicists who I guess are taking
the understanding that I couldn't even begin to
explain how one might test this experimentally.
So I assume it's largely theoretical at this
point, but those who take the consciousness
as fundamental side of things seem to try not to
use panpsychism, some of them. But how was Crick
approaching this, and why was it so compelling?
David Eagleman: Well, let me say two things. Okay,
so Crick had a chalkboard in his office,
and he had lots of things written on it,
but right in the middle, he had the word
meaning written on it because that was
his central question. Why does any of this mean
anything to us? I mean, if I look at my garage
door opener or my cell phone or whatever, it's
just pushing zeros and ones around in transistors
and presumably nothing means anything to it,
but we have all this feeling and meaning. So
that was his central question, and what he was
trying to figure out was what he called the NCC,
the neural correlates of consciousness.
So working with our mutual colleague,
Christof Koch, he was working on the NCC and
trying to figure out okay, look, there's the
hard problem of consciousness, which is why
does any of this equal subjective experience,
but the maybe easier problem is to figure out what
parts of the brain are involved and absolutely
have to be there for you to be consciously aware
of something. And so that's what he defined that
as a program and worked on that until he passed
away. But there are many other people who are
pursuing that in various ways. But again,
that's the easy problem of consciousness,
just figuring out the correlates.
Tim Ferriss: It's exciting.
Are there any of the 10 unsolved questions, if
I'm getting the headline right, of neuroscience,
of those 10 are if you're like, "You know what?
If I could have an XPRIZE, put something together
to make it so financially compelling that some
of the best scientists in the world would drop
what they're doing to focus on this, this
is the one or the two that I might choose."
Are there any that come to mind? They don't
even necessarily need to be from that piece.
They could be something that simply comes to mind.
David Eagleman: Actually, I'll tell — let me give
a slightly different answer to the question
because actually what I thought you might be
about to ask, "Are there any of the 10 that
we have made some progress on?" And actually
there is one and that has to do with why
we dream. And one of the questions was why
do brains sleep and dream? Sleep is still a
little complicated, but they've a bunch of
hypothesis. But I think that my student
and I've solved why we dream at night,
and I can tell you if you're interested in that.
Tim Ferriss: No, no, thanks. We're in a
rush here. Yeah, please go ahead, David.
David Eagleman: Which is, it has to do with brain
plasticity. So the brain is always reconfiguring
itself. It's a very dynamic system, and every one
of these neurons in your head where they look like
branching trees, and they make 10,000 connections
to other neurons, these are constantly moving.
So imagine moving trees that are plugging and
unplugging and seeking and connecting with
others and so on. So anyway, that's called
brain plasticity, this constant reconfiguration.
And it turns out the surprise in neuroscience is
how rapidly things can start moving and changing.
And so some colleagues mine at Harvard back in,
I think 2007, did this experiment where they
put people in fMRI, the brain scanner, and
they blindfolded them tightly. And they were doing
things like when you're exposed to sound or touch,
what's happening in the brain? And what they
found is that in 60 minutes, the visual system
started responding to touch and to sound, and
that was really unexpected because we know that
if you go blind, your visual system will get
taken over, especially if you're really young.
But no one would've ever dreamt that you'd start
seeing the first signs of takeover in 60 minutes.
And so that got my student and I to start
thinking about something right away. And
we realized that dreaming has to do with the
rotation of the planet. And this is because
the planet rotates into darkness. So we
spend half our time in the dark. Obviously,
I'm not talking about electricity-blessed times,
but historical evolutionary times. What this means
is you can still hear, and smell, and taste, and
touch, in the dark, but you can't see in the dark.
And that puts the visual system at a disadvantage.
It's like you have been blindfolded in a sense.
And so what we realized is the visual system has
to fight back to keep its territory all during
the night. And so that's what dreaming is about.
Every 90 minutes you've got these very specialized
circuits that blast activity just into the visual
cortex. That's all that happens in dreaming is
it's going just to primary visual cortex, all
this random activity. And it's just to keep
it defended against takeover from its neighbors.
Tim Ferriss: To prevent the weeds of other senses
from encroaching on the walled garden of vision.
David Eagleman: Exactly. You got it. You got
it. It's a screensaver. And so what's very
interesting is a lot of people have asked me,
when I present this — I'm presenting this at a big
talk at Stanford tomorrow, by the way. And a lot
of people say like, "Wait, don't we already
know why we dream?" And the answer is, "No,
we don't know why we dream." There are various
hypotheses, but that doesn't mean you stop making
hypotheses, and the reason this one matters, I
think, is because it is the first ever one that
makes quantitative predictions across species.
So what we did is we found 25 different species
of primates, and we looked at how plastic their
brains are. Some primates come out very plastic
like Homo sapiens, others, like the gray mouse
lemur, it's called is very not plastic. It drops
out, it reaches puberty rapidly. It knows
how to walk rapidly. It's pre-programmed,
if you want to think about it that way.
Tim Ferriss: What are you using as a proxy
or a measurement for plasticity?
David Eagleman: Great. So it's
time to wean from their mothers, time to walking,
time to puberty, things like this. So with a —
Tim Ferriss: I got it. So how much is out of the
box versus how much is molding of the Play-Doh?
David Eagleman: You got it. That's exactly it.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. Got it.
David Eagleman: And so Homo sapiens,
it's unbelievable. I mean, we're so useless
for so long, and that's because we've got these
extraordinary plastic brains. We drop into the
world half-baked, and we absorb the world around
us. We absorb the language, and the culture,
and all the knowledge that has come before us,
and that's why it takes us so long to develop. But
some of the other monkeys and apes or whatever,
they drop out, they're good to go. And if you look
at something like an alligator, it's just eat,
run, mate. That's all it's doing. There's nothing
other than the pre-programming that it needs.
Rapid eye movement sleep is what correlates
with dreaming. So if you look at the amount
of REM sleep that these different animals get,
you find that it correlates perfectly, like a
perfect machine gun correlation.
Tim Ferriss: More REM, more plasticity.
David Eagleman: Exactly. So if you are a creature
like — by the way, if you're a baby human,
you dream all the time. They have about 50 percent
of their sleep is REM sleep, is dream sleep. And
as you get older, your brain is less plastic. And
by the way, you have less percentage of REM sleep.
But anyway, for an animal that's not particularly
plastic, it has very little dream sleep.
Tim Ferriss: Are you aware of any counter
examples? Are there any species that seem to
exhibit a decent percentage of REM sleep, but
that one would not conclude are particularly
high plasticity outside of primates?
David Eagleman: No. I don't know any
counterexamples where they have a lot of
REM sleep, but I did come across one which
I thought was a real problem for the hypothesis,
which is elephants. Elephants have almost no REM
sleep. They do have a little bit of REM once in
a while, but otherwise they don't. And of course,
elephants have big brains and so on, but it turns
out elephants only sleep one to two hours a night,
and they have excellent night vision, so they
don't need to keep their visual cortex protected
against takeover in the same way that we do. So
that actually falls right into line in the theory.
Tim Ferriss: I wonder if there are other animals
with terrible night vision that might experience
a decent percentage of their sleep as REM sleep.
But I mean, it's a fascinating hypothesis. I mean,
super fascinating, and it simplifies the
whole thing and demystifies it if true.
David Eagleman: Exactly. Exactly. And again, when
you're blasting random activity, and because we're
visual animals, we have dreams. When you get
activity back there, you think, "Oh, I'm seeing
them riding through a meadow. I'm talking to
a silver leprechaun," whatever's going on.
Tim Ferriss: You too?
David Eagleman: What's funny about
dreams is, you wake up, and you try to explain
it to your spouse or whoever you're talking to,
and we layer on all this extra stuff in this
narrative to make it make sense. But actually,
dreams are just these weird visuals that happen.
Actually, let me just mention one thing because
I always get asked about, okay, what
about blind people? What happens in their
dreams? Do you know the answer to that?
Tim Ferriss: I don't. I would suspect it
probably depends on when they became blind and
the type of blindness, but I don't know the answer
to that. So why don't you take us there?
David Eagleman: If you are a blind person,
you still have dreams at night, and that's
because these circuits that drive dreaming are
very ancient. You find these across the entire
animal kingdom, actually. So every 90 minutes,
they get this random activity blasted into their
occipital lobe. But now that part of the brain is
no longer visual. So a blind person has dreams
that involve touch and hearing and so on. Like,
"Oh, I was feeling my way around the living
room and there was a big dog in the corner,
and I got scared and I ran, but the furniture
was all rearranged," and whatever, but it's all
touch and hearing. It's not visual.
Tim Ferriss: I interviewed Richard Turner,
who is a very famous, close-up magician who
is completely blind, and he became blind at a
pretty young age. And he described his experience
of reality, and we have to take his word for it,
of course, but highly visual. I didn't
ask him about his dreams, I don't think,
but really enjoyed the conversation because he
has the dexterity of a very well-trained sighted
person. It is nearly impossible to believe that
he is not fully sighted with what he can do with
his hands. It's remarkable. For people who are
interested, there's a documentary called Dealt,
D-E-A-L-T that is fantastic about Richard Turner.
David Eagleman: Oh, I'd love to see it.
Tim Ferriss: It's fantastic. I really
recommend it. There's a lot more to it than
just magic. I mean, it's mostly his life story.
David Eagleman: But I just want to point out,
it's not necessarily visual. It's spatial. So he's
got this amazing spatial sense it sounds like,
about what's where, and how to turn things,
and how to move things, and get things into
his pocket or whatever, but it's spatial.
Tim Ferriss: Well, he describes it in his
experience, keeping in mind that he was
sighted until he was something like six
or seven years old. I can't recall
exactly, but if I remember correctly,
different experiences have a blue or a red tone
to them and have different, I think he would say,
visual geometric representations depending on what
he's interacting with, who he's interacting with.
That doesn't invalidate what you said with respect
to dreaming. I don't think I asked him that,
but that's an area I know very little about.
David Eagleman: Oh, I'd love to get in touch
with him and ask him about his dreams.
Tim Ferriss: He's in San Antonio, Texas. I
could put you in touch if you wanted.
David Eagleman: Great.
Tim Ferriss: So let's talk about additional
influences. So we hit one of the big names, Crick.
Who are some of the influences that most shaped
where you are today and over the last say 10 years
as a scientist and just investigator of the world?
David Eagleman: I would say the ones that come to
mind are, first of all, my father who is
a forensic psychiatrist and just a super
smart guy. That was a big influence of my
life. Then I went to graduate school, and
my advisor was a guy named Read Montague, who
was such a terrific thinker and a great athlete,
and he was a major influence on me. And
the other one I guess was Carl Sagan,
who I only knew through television. But that was
all I saw as a kid. We never watched much TV,
but I saw Cosmos on PBS and it totally influenced
the shape of the trajectory of my life. I mean,
I just first of all was so turned on by all the
stuff he was saying and felt — it's interesting
actually, because my parents never said, "Oh,
you could be the next president of the United
States." They always would say, "Oh, you
could be the next Carl Sagan," and that's
the direction I ended up taking.
Tim Ferriss: Now I may have
missed the name. Montague?
David Eagleman: Montague, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Am I recalling that?
Montague. What was the impact that
was made and what sport, just out of curiosity?
David Eagleman: He was a decathlete. He was a
decathlete, and just unbelievably good at every
sport he ever tried. He was a big sprinter and
a big muscular guy. And somehow when I — look,
here's the thing. As an undergraduate, I majored
in British and American literature because that
was my first love. And so when I decided in
my last semester of my senior year that I loved
neuroscience, I applied to neuroscience graduate
school, and I miraculously got in, but I wasn't
sure if I wanted to do a PhD in neuroscience. I
didn't know what that would entail, and I figured
I'd end up with big Coke bottle glasses and my
hair sticking up everywhere. I didn't really know
what it meant to be a scientist. And so I met this
guy and he was so admirable in all the ways that
I wanted to be just as a killer in every way, and
so smart. He was 20 IQ points ahead of everybody,
and also could bench press and do chin-ups better
than everybody. And so he was real impressive.
Tim Ferriss: So he broke the mold. So he showed
you that you didn't need to be resigned to the
Coke bottle glasses. Was that proof of concept?
David Eagleman: Yeah, it was proof of concept,
and of course, the ideas, and the challenges, and
whatever that it opened up my world. It opened up
my mind so enormously. And he was very hard on me.
I was his grad student for five years, and he was
a total jerk all the time. But I love the guy so
much, but he was really hard on me the whole time.
Tim Ferriss: Would you, in retrospect,
have it any other way?
David Eagleman: No.
Tim Ferriss: Is there a version of the
hard that would be better or would've
potentially been better for you? Or
was it what you needed at the time?
David Eagleman: I suspect this is different for
each person, but for me, it worked really well.
And I had a coach, a track coach in high school,
who was the same way. He was so mean to me,
and it brought out my best behaviors that way.
Tim Ferriss: So
going from British American lit to deciding that
you're going to apply for a master's program
in neuroscience seems like a very hard left
turn. Two questions. So you said very luckily,
something along those lines, I got in, but there's
got to be a little more to the story. So what was
the pitch, maybe in the form of essays or maybe
it's combined with standardized testing. I have
no idea what the prereqs were or the application
process was like, but why decide to dedicate
that time to neuroscience? Were you maybe buying
yourself a little bit of time to figure out what
was next? And then what do you think, if you
had to make an educated guess, helped you to
get in from such an seemingly unrelated field?
David Eagleman: The truth is that I was always
studying science. And so I had tons of science
on my transcript. It's just that I didn't have
neuroscience in particular. And so what had
happened is I was really good at science
growing up, and so everyone told me, I feel
like everyone gave me bad advice. They said,
"Oh, you should become an actuary and do the stuff
with math" because I could do math or "You should
become a waste engineer because there's a lot of
money in waste engineering." People had all these
proposals that were so boring and nothing
to do with Carl Sagan and real questions.
So what happened is I went to college, and I
studied electrical engineering. I took lots
of physics. I took lots of all kinds of things
and I couldn't quite find what was resonating.
I couldn't find the thing that I loved.
And so I ended up majoring in literature,
but I was taking these classes and it was my last
semester that I took a neuroscience class. And by
the way, the class I took was taught by a very old
professor who was using literature from let's say
the 1960s. It was a terrible neuroscience class,
but it didn't matter at all. I was totally hooked.
Tim Ferriss: And so it seems like
you had demonstrated scientific
chops. You're not enumerate. You can do
math. Was there anything else that was
key do you think, to getting into that program?
David Eagleman: Actually, in one of my philosophy
classes, we'd been assigned to write a final
project and I don't know, a 12-page assignment
or something. I ended up writing 108 pages on
the brain. And the reason I was writing so much
on it is because I went to the library and I, over
the course of that last semester, read every book
that the library had on the brain, which, by the
way, was not that many at the time because there
just weren't that many. But I read everything.
So when I showed up for the graduate school
interview, I said, "Look, I know I don't have much
biology on my transcript, but ask me what I know,
and I'll tell you because I've read X, Y, Z, and
blah blah," and it worked. The problem is I don't
think a kid could get into graduate school now
with that trajectory, and I think that's a shame.
Tim Ferriss: Why not?
David Eagleman: Well, only because now
the competition is so high, and so if you haven't
rotated in labs the whole time you're an undergrad
and been doing neuroscience since you were two
years old and so on, then it's hard to get in.
Tim Ferriss: And then the David Eaglemans
of the world end up being waste engineers.
No disrespect to waste engineers, but you would
hope there to be a spectrum of possibilities.
David Eagleman: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Well, it's good that you
went through it when you did then, I suppose.
David Eagleman: Yeah. Oh,
exactly. I really lucked out.
Tim Ferriss: What would you say is one of your,
for those people listening and looking at your
bio and watching your TED talks and think, "Man,
this guy just wakes up every morning and just
karate chops the universe to bend his will and
hits home runs from start to finish. I can't
believe it. That's not me," Favorite failures,
and you can define that any way you'd like, but to
frame it, failures or things that didn't work out
as you had hoped, that in retrospect taught you a
lot, bent your trajectory, or maybe set the stage
for later successes? Anything that comes to mind?
David Eagleman: Well, one thing that comes to
mind is I wanted to be a writer very much,
and so I wrote my first book called Sum.
Tim Ferriss: Great book, by
the way, highly recommend.
David Eagleman: Thank you very much. And I
submitted it for publication and I got rejected,
so I submitted again, I got rejected. I ended up
collecting a stack of rejection letters as high
as the book. Nobody wanted to publish it. And
some people, most of they were form rejections,
but some people hand wrote stuff saying, "Hey, I
really liked this book, but I have no idea where
I would put this in the bookshelf or I don't even
understand what this thing is," and so that was a
failure that just kept dragging on for a very
long time. I had written it over seven years
and I was pretty much certain that it was never
actually going to get to see the light of day.
And then finally, I just kept trying to crush it
from different angles, and I finally came up with
an idea of there was a particular literary agent
that I wanted to hit, and so I managed to figure
out three different ways to hit her so that within
48 hours, she was hearing from three different
people. Finally, she said, "I will take you on as
a hip pocket client," which just means, "You're
not really a client in mine, but I'll keep you
in my pocket just in case I see an opportunity."
And then she called me two days later and
she was incredulous and she said, "Wow,
Sum just got bought," so that was the start of
a big thing. And Tim, I know you've read the —
Tim Ferriss: Hold on, hold on, hold on, so before
you get there, you're skipping over something
really important. Two days later, seven years in
the making, "Sum just got bought." How does that
happen? Did she just send it out to some folks
and said, "Ah, I'm never going to hear back,
but fuck it. Why not? Let's try it."
David Eagleman: Exactly. Look, it took me a while
to learn that this is what literary agents are
about. They're the first filter and if an agent
says, "I'll take something on," then a publisher
will actually take a look at it, but I had been
trying to write the publishers directly.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
David Eagleman: Tim, I know you know the book and
the book became an international bestseller and
pretty immediately got published in 33 languages.
It got turned into two operas. Brian Eno
turned it into an opera at the Sydney Opera House.
Tim Ferriss: Didn't know that part.
David Eagleman: Oh, okay. Yes.
Tim Ferriss: That's amazing.
David Eagleman: Eno turned into opera and then
around the same time, Max Richter turned it into
an opera at the Royal Opera House of London.
And it finds itself back in the top 100 books
on Amazon over the years, and so it's been such
a special part of my life, but the point is that
it was such a long, extended failure and I'm so
thankful that I just kept banging on that door
until it finally creeped open accidentally.
Tim Ferriss: What kept you going? Well, two
questions. Why write it in the first place? Not
to bury this, for people who don't know, Sum, the
subtitle is 40 Tales from the Afterlives, that's
plural. And you know what? If you don't mind, I'll
just read what I put in my newsletter years ago
when I first read it, and I won't read all of it,
but I'll mention some of it. This is what I put,
and you can correct me if I got anything wrong.
"Don't let the title of this book fool you. It
isn't making a case for the afterlife. Instead,
this short read, easy to finish in
two days is a collection of 40 thought
exercises on the nature of existence, reality,
perception, death, pain, boredom, and more.
At the very least, it should make you appreciate
your own life, warts and all, much more."
And then in the official book description, "In
one afterlife, you may find God is the size of a
microbe and unaware of your existence. In another
version, you work as a background character in
other people's dreams or you may find that God
is a married couple or that the universe is
running backward or that you're forced to live out
your afterlife with annoying versions of who you
could have been." Why write this book and what
gave you the gumption, the persistence to keep
going? Because that doesn't always happen, to be
clear. There are plenty of high-achieving people
who start books and finish them, get rejected,
and after a while, they stop. Why did you end
up hitting this agent from multiple angles? Why
the book and then why did you end up continuing
and hitting this agent from multiple angles?
David Eagleman: Why the book actually started
when I was, I think, 11 years old and I
ended up talking to a rabbi and I said, "Hey,
I've never understood, what is the Jewish view of
the afterlife?" And he said, "Well, you ask three
Jews, you'll get four opinions," and I thought
that was so amazing because I'd never heard
someone say something like that before. That was
actually the seed of the book and that's the why.
Anyway, and then again, as a lover of literature
and a writer, I found this concept of the
afterlife such a great backdrop upon which to ask
all kinds of questions. And as you know from the
book, it's funny and there's pathos and — anyway.
I do know exactly why I kept going and that was
because of a 16-year-old kid that I met when I
was at the Salk Institute with Francis Crick,
actually. What happened is there was a high school
science day and these kids came over and I talked
to them about what I was doing and one of the
kids came up to me afterwards and said, "Can
I work with you? This is what I want to do. Can I
work with you?" And I said, "Sure, write down your
phone number on the dry erase board here."
And he did. And the next day, the dry erase
board got erased and so I forgot about the kid.
Then I get a voicemail from him saying, "Hey,
I'm the kid, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah." Okay.
And then I thought, "Oh, I've got to call this guy
back" and then I forgot. And then I get a letter
from his high school teacher saying, "Hey, this
is just a letter to recommend the kid." Then I get
called from him again. Then I get an email and I
thought, "Wait a minute. I don't want to miss this
kid. This kid's amazing." He ended up working in
my lab and for the last 16 years has been my
closest collaborator. His name is Don Vaughn.
Tim Ferriss: Amazing. That's incredible.
David Eagleman: And I call this the Don Vaughn
method of just hitting someone over and over from
different angles to make sure that they don't
forget — I was so impressed by this, because I was
busy and I couldn't remember to call him back and
whenever, and so I was really impressed with this,
and so when I was trying to get Sum published at
the end there, I thought explicitly, "I'm going
to do the Don Vaughn method and I'm going to hit
this agent from every angle that I can."
Tim Ferriss: That's incredible. And it worked.
David Eagleman: Yeah, it worked.
Tim Ferriss: That's remarkable.
Speaking of literature, I think this is from The
New York Times a long time ago, but you've said
that Gabriel García Márquez, Italo Calvino, Jorge
Luis Borges, Toni Morrison, and William Faulkner
are among some of your literary influences, maybe
heroes. Feel free to add more, but I'm curious for
someone who has not read, let's assume someone
hasn't read anything from any of these writers.
Are there two or three books that come to
mind that you might suggest people start with?
David Eagleman: Yeah. Italo Calvino's Invisible
Cities is an extraordinary book about Marco Polo
talking to the Great Khan, Kublai Khan, about
different cities in the Khan's Empire, and
it's magical realism. And by the way, all five of
those authors that you named, that I guess I named
back in that article in 2011, all five of them,
they're all magical realism, which means it's not
just writing about the day-to-day stuff, but just
feeling free to go off in crazy directions about
things that shouldn't be possible and they just
make it possible. I've always loved that style
of writing. All five of those are really still my
favorites all these years later. A Hundred Years
of Solitude, if someone hasn't read that, Borges'
Labyrinths, Toni Morrison's Beloved, essentially
anything by Faulkner, The Bear is a great one.
Tim Ferriss: I'll add one more to the list for
people who are looking for something very strange
and it's also very short, but I think it's The
Baron in the Trees by Italo Calvino, which is
about basically a young boy who gets in a fight
with his father, comes from this esteemed
family, escapes into the tree in his yard,
and never comes down for the rest of his life,
and he builds this entire life in the trees in
the canopy. It's about as strange as it sounds.
You mentioned the word hypothesis has come up a
bunch in this conversation and you've said
in, I think, it was Smithsonian Magazine,
that you encourage your son to do
hypothesis testing. Could you speak to
this and just explain what that might look like?
David Eagleman: Oh, yeah. It's anytime he says,
"Hey, Dad, how does this work?" And I've got
a daughter now, too, and so you'll say, "Hey,
how does this work?" I say, "Well, how do you
think it works?" So they come up with an idea
and I say, "Okay, cool. Can you come up with
another idea?" They come up with another. "Okay,
great. Now how would we test that? How would you
distinguish those two ideas?" That's what it is to
come up with something on your own and figure out
how to test it, because whether or not they become
scientists, I mean, they probably won't, for all I
know, but definitely want them to be good thinkers
and be able to figure things out so they're
not dependent on dogma or what their neighbor
tells them is the answer, that sort of thing.
Tim Ferriss: If you were giving advice to, say,
let's put you back in the realm of academia,
so you've got a super promising postdoc, one
of the smartest you've ever met, maybe has some
IP that has spun out or something that has spun
out into a full-time, I shouldn't say full-time,
for-profit company, and they come to you to ask
for time management or advice, prioritization
advice, just general life management and advice,
because they fear that they're going to get
overwhelmed. They look at your life. They say,
"This is the guy who can do anything. He's
the decathlete of business and science,"
and put in that situation, what advice might
you give them or what might you say to them?
David Eagleman: I would only be able to give what
I do, and that is the lazy Susan method. Do you
know what lazy Susan is?
Tim Ferriss: I do.
David Eagleman: It's the circular
thing that sits in the middle of the
table. Okay. Not everyone knows what this is —
Tim Ferriss: You can spin it around to get
different dishes around the table.
David Eagleman: Exactly. It turns out,
I learned a long time ago that Walt Whitman
would do this with his writing projects. Each
segment in the lazy Susan, he'd have a different
writing project, and he would work on something
until he was slowing down, and then he'd spin
it and randomly pick a different project and
work on that, and that is precisely what I do. I
loved seeing that story about him because that's
my life. I work on whatever I am maximally
resonating with at that moment and as soon as
I start slowing down or get stuck, I just jump to
a different project. And when I come back to the
thing I had been working on, I'm more
refreshed in a sense, or I've thought
of a new idea about it, that kind of thing.
Tim Ferriss: Where do you keep this lazy Susan?
Presumably, it's not a physical lazy Susan.
David Eagleman: Not physical, just in my
prefrontal cortex. Yeah. Spin it around there.
Tim Ferriss: If we could take a closer look
at this prefrontal lazy Susan for a second,
let's just take this upcoming week. We're
talking on a Monday and I don't know what
your calendar looks like. Maybe you could just
describe the architecture of your week a little
bit. That would actually be very helpful.
David Eagleman: A lot of it is work meetings
with my company, Neosensory. Some of
it is meetings with VCs about that.
Then I have various lectures I'm giving. It
happens that this week, several of them are
virtual lectures, so that's a lot easier for me.
Then working on how to do B2B stuff, business
to business stuff, because we're now selling the
wristband not only to customers, but directly to
big businesses with big warehouses for their deaf
employees. But then, let's see, I'm giving a talk
to a bunch of Stanford students. Then I run
the Center for Science and Law, which is where
neuroscience and the legal system intersects,
so I'm having some meetings about that.
I also just finished a book about, okay, this is a
little embarrassing because it's so unusual. It's
so different than anything else I've written,
but it's a young adult book or middle grade,
but it's about a brother and sister team who solve
mysteries like Hardy Boys or Encyclopedia Brown,
but all the mysteries have to do with the
brain, so it's really, I think, educational
and lovely. But anyway, so I'm having a meeting
about that, and then it happens at tomorrow's
my birthday, so unfortunately —
Tim Ferriss: Happy birthday.
David Eagleman: Thank you. Unfortunately, I'm
looking at my calendar, it turns out I have
zero time on my calendar to do anything
that would resemble birthdayness, but —
Tim Ferriss: Maybe that is the
quintessential David Eagleman
birthday is a calendar that's completely full.
David Eagleman: That sucks. Then I teach
neural law at Stanford on Thursday. Then
I'm having dinner with a startup that I'm
advising. Then I'm doing my podcast, actually,
twice this week on Tuesday and on Friday. I'm
doing a three-hour recording session.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. This is very helpful,
a glimpse behind the curtain, and what I'd love
to know is if you had to pick something in there,
to use this hypothetical with the lazy Susan, is
there anything that you could walk us through?
Let's say you're getting ready to do the podcast.
You're prepping for hours and you're just like,
"You know what? I am fucking exhausted and
it's my birthday. I don't want to be doing
this right now." Is that the type of case that
you might have, where then you would switch to
something else, in which case, which is not to
throw the podcast under the bus. I'm trying to
find something where you're not fully obligated
to other people, because I imagine when you're
in a Zoom meeting, if you're 30 minutes into 60
minutes, you're probably disinclined to be like,
"You know what, guys? My heart's not in it. I'm
going to focus on my new young adult book that
I'm working on." Is there anything in this week
where you might be able to hypothetically describe
how the lazy Susan might work?
David Eagleman: Unfortunately,
the lazy Susan can only get spun on the weekends
or something, when there's opportunity to think.
This week happens to be a pretty tough one, so
I'm constrained in every moment and I just have
to perform. The lazy Susan comes in when I say,
"Wow, I've got a four-hour chunk and I'm going
to sit down at IHOP." By the way, I've written all
my books at IHOPs. I don't know why, but I love —
Tim Ferriss: I love that.
David Eagleman: Yeah. It's bottomless
coffee and it's quiet. It's not like a Starbucks,
where attractive people are walking in and out
all the time, whatever. It's just quiet and
boring and you can just drink coffee and write,
but that's where I spin it, because what happens
is I'll work on something and then I'll say, "Oh,
yeah. I really want to get to this other thing,"
and so I'll spin it and do the other thing.
Tim Ferriss: That makes sense. Do you think
about how much of that solo time you want to
block out on a weekly, monthly, quarterly,
annual basis, anything along those lines,
because I would imagine otherwise,
it's a slippery slope and you end up
committed to a large chunk of your waking life
involving other people, so there's a social
pressure expectation that you will not cancel or
move things around, so it maybe creates a degree
of inflexibility. Do you think about that?
David Eagleman: Yes, I do think about that
all the time. And I really admire, Tim,
your 4-Hour Workweek as an example. I'm
working on the 400-hour work week and it sucks
because I'm totally constrained on all fronts.
Tim Ferriss: You seem to be having a good time.
David Eagleman: I'm having a good time and it's
my own fault and my wife accuses me of — I choose
it, obviously. The thing is I can't resist new,
shiny objects, so every time some student
says, "Hey, I want to start a company. Will
you help me and be an advisor?" I'm like,
"Heck, yeah. That sounds amazing," and I
do that. Every time I come up with a new idea
for a screenplay or book or whatever, I'm like,
"That's the greatest idea," and I jump in on it.
Tim Ferriss: You may not want to start a venture
capital firm. You'll end up saying yes to
everything. Actually, one of my mentors,
Ed Zschau, incredible entrepreneur, also was a
competitive figure skater, then a congressman,
and took a couple of companies public. He taught
computer science. I think he was the first or
maybe the second to ever teach computer science
at Stanford and he tried to become a venture
capitalist. He did become one at one point and
he realized, "I'm not any good at this. I get
too excited." I'm just saying.
David Eagleman: Nice.
Tim Ferriss: Let's talk about Livewired. And this
question was cued for me, in a way, by Annaka
Harris, who's an incredible writer, who's written
a lot on consciousness. The topic we covered at
the very beginning of this conversation on some
level, infotropism. Am I getting this term right?
David Eagleman: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Could you walk us through the
premise of Livewired, the reason for writing it,
and then unpack infotropism, if you wouldn't mind?
David Eagleman: Yeah. Okay, so Livewired in
general is about this issue of how you can't
really think about the brain like hardware or
software, but instead it's what I call liveware,
where it's reconfiguring itself all the
time, this thing I mentioned earlier,
brain plasticity. There's something like 30,000
papers a year coming out on brain plasticity now,
but I wrote this book to synthesize and build the
framework for understanding what it is for the
brain to absorb the world around it and do that.
What I surfaced that way were some principles
that were interesting to me and one of them is
about, infotropism is a term that I coined about
what the brain is trying to do at all
times. It's reconfiguring its circuitry
so that it can maximize the information
that it brings in from the world.
Just as an example, if
you're watching a waterfall,
we've probably all had the experience.
You're staring at a waterfall for a while,
and then you look over to the rocks of trees at
the side and it looks like everything's moving
up. This is called the motion aftereffect, where
you see motion moving in the opposite direction.
I make a long argument, but I'll just say in a
sentence here that what the brain's trying to
do is say, "Okay, I'm going to reset my zero. I'm
going to recalibrate so that I can see if there's
more information here because I don't want to
just…" Essentially what it would be trying to
do is cancel out the downward motion because it
says, "Okay, there's lots of that, but there's
no new information there, so I'm trying to
cancel that out," and it does it by having
this upward motion. There's more sophisticated
arguments about how it does this neurally.
It's doing that to maximize the information.
Same if I change the color of the lights in the
room, let's say I make it all red. Your brain will
quickly stop seeing the red and it will adjust
itself so that it's seeing other things, so it can
maximize what it's pulling out at all times. Of
course, you know this. If you put on, let's say,
yellow sunglasses or something, everything looks
normal after a moment until you take them off
again. Anyway, this is a general thing that the
brain's always trying to do, is say, "How can I
pull the most useful information out of the world
by recalibrating everything else around me?"
Tim Ferriss: What was your hope in publishing
that book? What would you like people
to take from that or what would you
like people to grab and run with from that?
David Eagleman: I think the notion of how
plastic the brain actually is is something that's
totally underappreciated. There's an idea that I
think many people have, which is, "Oh, you're
just born with the brain. The brain unpacks
and then you're who you are," but really, we
are totally functions of our culture and our
society. And one of the things that's amazing
to me is, imagine, Tim, that you and I were born
10,000 years ago, exactly the same DNA, but
we wouldn't be anything like what we are
now. Even though with the same DNA we might look
vaguely like we do now, but my God, the culture,
everything we're pulling in would be so different.
And that's what actually shapes a human being.
And I actually started off the book with a
quotation from Heidegger who says — oh, it's
something like, "Every man begins life as 10,000
men and dies as a single one." And what that
means is you've got all this potential, all these
directions you could go in your life, but as you
move through life and you make choices and stuff
happens to you, you end up as exactly who you are.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. I'm looking at Martin
Heidegger. I just wanted to find it.
Tell me if this sounds right to you.
"Anyone can achieve their fullest potential.
Who we are might be predetermined, but the path
we follow is always of our own choosing. We should
never allow our fears or the expectations of
others to set the frontiers of our destiny." And
then, there's the popup to continue with Facebook.
Thank you, Goodreads. They come by. "Your destiny
can't be changed, but it can be challenged. Every
man is born as many men and dies as a single one."
David Eagleman: Right, right, right. Nice.
Tim Ferriss: So let me ask you then about
just a thought exercise. If we look through the
telescope into the future or the probably the
scrying ball. Look into the scrying ball and try
to figure out what might be coming down the pike,
knowing what you know and having the breadth
of exposure that you have within science and
outside of science, let's just say in the next 10
years, the next decade, what current assumptions
about the brain perception or reality do you think
potentially going to be overturned or that might
be ripe for challenging. Is there anything?
David Eagleman: I think the main thing has to
do with technology as opposed to theoretical
ideas. So, what I mean is we've got plenty
of theoretical hypotheses all about how
the brain might be working and so on,
but we actually don't have any good technology for
measuring what's going on inside the brain. So,
we've got brain imaging where you see these
fancy images of brains with the false color
images on it and so on, but it's really crude.
That's fMRI. That's just measuring where the
blood flow goes, and you're measuring cubes
of millions and millions of neurons at once,
and all you can say is, "Oh, there was some
activity there somewhere in that cube."
So, what we really need is a technology that
allows us to measure the spiking activity of
every neuron in the brain, let's say 86 billion
neurons all at once in real time, ideally,
and then, do massive computational analysis of
that to understand what is the language of the
brain. Somehow, we know it involves these spikes,
but we don't crack the neural code yet. So, in
the same way that Francis Crick and James Watson
cracked the genetic code, "Oh, it's ACTG," and the
whole thing is just about keeping the order of the
base pairs and all the rest is just housekeeping.
We haven't figured out what
the neural code is yet. So,
what we're facing — I don't know if it'll be 10
years, hopefully, maybe it'll be 20 or 100, but
what we're facing is a giant leap in understanding
that we know is coming, but we just don't have the
trick cracked yet. So that's one thing.
Was your question about any kind of
invention or neuroscience in particular?
Tim Ferriss: It could be broader than
neuroscience, but I was thinking related
to the brain, the mind perception, but
really anything that checks any of those boxes,
but we can go beyond that. What I find so
mesmerizing and frustrating about humans, and of
course, I'm one of those, so I put myself in the
same group, it's just how certain we are at so
many points. And I know you have quoted Voltaire
before saying "Uncertainty is an uncomfortable
position, but certainty is an absurd one."
But if you look back, especially, in the
history of medicine, let's just say at
how certain humans are including — let's just
call them top specialists in any given field
that what they know to be true or think to be
true is true. And then, it gets overturned,
and then, it gets overturned again, and then, it
gets overturned again, which is not to create a
relativism that we can't know anything. I
think that's a learned hopelessness that's
not very helpful. But I'm wondering, as someone
who has experience as a practitioner of science,
also an observer of science, a communicator
of science, a deep thinker on these subjects,
what might be worth stress testing or things
that we currently take to be true that may
in fact not be true. Doesn't need to
be contained in neuroscience though.
David Eagleman: This is the beauty of science is
that it's always willing to knock down its own
walls. And so, this is what the scientific
method is about, and it's the most special
thing that humans have ever done because
everything else is about how do I establish
my throne? And I set this up, and no one can
question this, but there's nothing in science
that isn't vulnerable to getting knocked off its
pedestal. And so, in fact, much earlier in the
podcast when you asked me about maybe view of
consciousness, whether it's emergent property
or whether consciousness is a fundamental, who
the heck knows? And I think as you get older
and more mature as a scientist, you feel like,
"Okay, I don't know. I don't know. We'll see.
We'll do experiments. We'll figure it out." But
there's no need to pretend certainty on things.
And in fact, that's always driven me crazy.
And one thing I — I walked into a bookstore.
This is many years ago. About the time that Sum
came out, actually. Walked into a bookstore and
there was a table of books on the front, and
one was by religious fundamentalists, one pile,
and the other pile was by the neo atheists.
And the table was set up as this battle
between these. But as you know from reading Sum,
it's all about shining a flashlight around the
possibility space. It's all about saying, "God,
who knows what's going on here? Let's just make
up a bunch of stories. Let's make up 40 stories,
and we can make up 400 more." And so, that idea,
you may know this, but years ago I proposed this
new movement called Possibilianism, which really
cut on actually is still moving around the planet.
Well, but the idea with Possibilianism is
avoiding, committing to something with
certainty if you don't need to. And really,
this is just an expression of the scientific
temperament. This science is always one say,
"Look. What we can have is the weight of
evidence at any given time." We can say, "Oh,
that supports this more than this. Okay, great."
So, we'll provisionally believe this to be true,
but it's not about pretending certainty when we
don't have enough data. And when it comes to some
fundamental questions like our existence here,
what the heck? I mean, we don't have any data on
that. We don't have enough to know if we should
be. I mean, certainly religion, we have enough
data to know that all those biblical stories are
completely made up and wrong in a thousand ways,
but we certainly don't have enough evidence to
say, "Oh, therefore there's nothing interesting
in the cosmos besides us." I mean, who knows?
Tim Ferriss: In my very limited muggle experience
of science, and life, really, the best people.
They're true outliers in terms of intellectual
horsepower and performance say, "I don't know
a lot." And I remember going on a walk with
someone recently and they wanted to get my two
cents back channel reference check on someone,
and my commentary was pretty simple. It was, well,
clearly very smart in a lot of ways, but almost no
low-conviction statements. And that makes me a
little nervous. Everything is a high-conviction
statement, and that gives me some pause.
So, you're right. I think the reserving
the space for uncertainty and to the extent
possible for me at least, trying to find that
exciting, the fact that there's still so much
unmapped territory as opposed to debilitating.
David, I'm going to ask you a question
that is sometimes a terrible question,
but I'll throw it out there anyway and
we can delete it if it doesn't pan out,
which is the metaphorical billboard question,
if you could put anything on a billboard,
non-commercial, of course, to get out to
hundreds of millions or billions of people,
could be a quote, could be a word, could
be an image, could be someone else's quote,
anything at all. Does anything come to mind?
David Eagleman: I think I would put a billboard
next to an elementary school, or maybe junior
high or high school. I don't know. I'd have to
think about this. But something like: "Question
your truth," because this is the issue that we're
always in is I've been fascinated by this issue.
So, the brain, locked in silence and darkness,
comes up with an internal model of the world
with all of its truths, its political truths,
all that stuff. And the funny part is that
when you look at someone else, let's say on
the opposite side of the political spectrum from
wherever you are, you think, "Oh, that person's
misinformed. They're a troll. If I just talked to
them long enough, they'd come to agree with me,”
and so on, and it's weird. Everybody believes
this, and everyone on all sides of the spectrum
thinks, "Okay, I clearly see the truth, and I
don't know why those other people don't." And so
I've just been fascinated by this issue about how
completely we believe our internal models. So,
that's what I would try to do with young people
anyway is just get them to question this issue
to minimize their high-conviction statements.
Tim Ferriss: So, how would you — let's just
use the elementary school or high school example.
This applies to more than that, but let's just say
in this case, how would you try to frame this or
spin it so that there's some self-interest, right?
In terms of not just the, maybe more general,
become a better thinker, a better human,
a better member of society, is
there a way that you could position
that cross-examination of one's own thoughts and
beliefs in maybe crasser way for self-interest?
Just to get more people to do it, right?
David Eagleman: Okay, I don't know if this
is going to answer the question directly,
but one way to get people there is to,
for example, if you admire Sherlock Holmes,
or if a kid watches the Benedict Cumberbatch
version or whatever, you think, "Wow, that
guy is really noticing things," and that's
when you start realizing the limits of your
own internal model, and I think, "I would've
never noticed that." Why? Because I didn't pay
attention to that. I didn't care about that.
But if you admire people who can do things
and solve things, then I think it's in your
self-interest to say, "I want to expand my
internal model. I'm not satisfied to say,
'Okay, I've got it. I know the truth. I'm
not going to do anymore work.'" So, something
along those lines of inspiring people that way.
Tim Ferriss: Well, I suppose House would fit in
there, but he's kind of a dick as a character, so
I'm not sure if you want your kids modeling that.
What's the impetus? And I mean, maybe this
is part of the impetus behind the book
that you're working on for kids?
David Eagleman: Yeah. Oh,
the one for kids. Is that —
Tim Ferriss: Oh, well, wait,
maybe — look, you've got so many projects I
can't keep track. Maybe there's another book?
David Eagleman: The one for kids is done, and
that's off to the publisher. But the one that I'm
working on, the big one I'm working on is called
Empire of the Invisible, and it's going to take me
another few years to finish this, but it is —
Tim Ferriss: Nice title.
David Eagleman: Thank you. It's all about this
issue of all the stuff we don't see and don't
understand. So, I start off with some examples, we
talked about with the electromagnetic spectrum or
all the light you don't see but forget it. It's
all about the stuff that you think your model
is complete and everything out there to know. But
fundamentally, your perception is like a Potemkin
village where you just see the facades of things.
And if I scratch the surface on any — if I were
to ask you, "Hey, do you know how the electoral
college works?" You'd say, "Yeah." And I'd say,
"Okay. Can you explain it to me?" And as soon —
Tim Ferriss: And I'd say no.
David Eagleman: Yeah, exactly. So, as soon
you start scratching the surface on things,
most people are like, "Oh, I thought I
knew, but maybe I don't really know." So,
that's what it's about, and how we can expand
our perception by asking questions all the time
by not taking our truths so seriously,
by understanding there's more out there.
That's what it's about, and I'm really
jazzed about this book. It's right now,
it's already 120,000 words. And so, I've got
to — as I'm finishing it, I got to really
crunch it down so that any human will read it.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, so, for people who don't
make any sense of word counts, I mean, I'd say a
lot of books that get published are around 50,000,
60,000, something like that, so
you're punching above your weight.
David Eagleman: 75 is my typical — yeah. Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: 75. How many words was Sum?
David Eagleman: Oh, that was like 30,000.
Tim Ferriss: Very, yeah. Much shorter.
David Eagleman: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I wonder if — just to bring
up the term that one cannot escape these days,
but I wonder if AI, in the cultural conversation
context, as people learn more about AI's plural
and large language models and training data, if
more people will become aware of their own blind
spots, since we all have our own training data,
right?
David Eagleman: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I wonder if as more
of these topics become mainstream,
find their way into scripted television and so
on, if people will become more aware of their
own limitations. I mean, that would be a lofty
hope. Not sure if that's going to be the case.
David Eagleman: I love it. I'm not sure. I'm not
sure I see how though because we're still stuck
in our internal models. So, even if I'm talking
to ChatGPT, and it tells me all kinds of things
I didn't know, now, I know those. Each time I
add something new to my internal model I think,
"Okay, now I'm complete. I didn't know
that. Now, I know. Great. I've got it now."
So I'm not sure how —
Tim Ferriss: Well, what I mean by that is,
for instance, we've been experimenting on my team
with summarizing past episodes using ChatGPT,
which I think is an incredible tool. But
what happens in some instances, is it the
chat interface where I should say the backend
won't interact just with the training data?
Because I'm curious to see how it behaves with
different parameters. It won't base its summary
strictly on the transcript that's available
on my website, it will also pull from, say,
Google, but much of what has been translated
or interpreted or even summarized elsewhere
is completely inaccurate, right? So, I'll go
through, or a team member will go through,
and they'll find all these mistakes, and
it's like, "Okay, interesting." If we're
looking at this as all-seeing, all-knowing sort
of monolith of tech that provides us with answers,
we have a lot of problems to solve. It's been
a useful tool for me to explore the limitations
of sets of training data, but maybe I wouldn't
expect it to have that effect across the board.
David Eagleman: Well, remember, it's not
all-seeing, all-knowing in terms of knowing
the truth. All it is its read everything,
and it's giving you a summary of everything,
so if there's —
Tim Ferriss: Totally.
David Eagleman: If there are people
with different interpretations of
what you talked about, that's what it'll know.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. But it'll serve it up as a
summary. But we don't need to belabor
the point. It's just that I've found
it to be an interesting exercise.
So let me ask this, and this is in some
exploratory bullets that I have listed in front
of me that I was hoping to get to. So, the one
that I would love to talk about before we start
to wrap is how to make it seem as though you're
living longer. And perhaps you could provide
a little connective tissue to this in context
in reading about your history, the story of the
construction site, when you were eight years old,
also, I thought gave a very interesting case
study perhaps of how perception of time can differ
depending on what you're experiencing. But where
do you think it would make sense to take this?
David Eagleman: So when I was a kid, I
fell off of this house under construction,
and I fell 12 feet, and it seemed to take a long
time. And I got really interested in this issue
of does time run in slow motion when you're in
fear for your life? I mean, I got interested
in that question once I became a neuroscientist
and had grown up. And so, I did this experiment.
I think you know about this where I dropped
people from a 150-foot tall tower in free fall,
falling backwards, and they're caught in a
net below. And I measured the speed of their
perception as they're falling because everybody
either has this experience or knows somebody with
this experience where they get in a car accident
and things seem to run in slow motion, and they
can report all these details of what happened.
Anyway, long story short, it turns out that the
whole thing is a trick of memory. People don't
actually perceive faster during a scary event.
It's just that they laid down more memory.
So, when they read this back out, they say,
"What just happened? What just happened?" It seems
like they've got much more memory than they would
in normal circumstances. So, they say, "I watched
the hood crumple and the rearview mirror fall off,
and the expression on the other guy's face, and
then," blah, blah, blah. Okay. So anyway, that
got me thinking about this issue about how we lay
down memory. And it turns out that we touched on
memory a while ago, but most things in your life
you do not remember. The number of cracks in the
sidewalk, and who was wearing what, and what was
on the menu on the wall that you — we just don't
remember almost everything because the job of
memory is to write down stuff that matters, that's
emotionally salient or informationally relevant.
And so, you're just writing this tiny fraction.
But anyway, when you're estimating
how long it's been since some event,
the way you estimate that is by drawing on the
footage that you have saying, "Oh, well see,
this happened, this happened this…" Okay, so that
must have been two months since I saw my friend,
or it must have been two years since I
saw this other person, that kind of thing.
So, anyway, this was a whole bunch of
research in my lab over the course of
a decade that came together. But the point
is, if you're laying down richer memories,
you won't necessarily live longer, but you will
make it seem as though you've lived longer.
Because when you're asking what just happened
or how long has it been, you've got more data,
more footage to draw on. And of course,
we all know this feeling when you go on
some super exciting trip on the weekend and you
come back and you're back on a Monday, you think,
"Oh my gosh, it's been forever since it was
Friday. There's so many things that happened." But
if you just have a normal weekend, you think, 'Oh
my gosh, it's Monday. It was just Friday." There's
nothing to write down, and so you don't feel
that there was much duration that happened there.
So, this is why I think one of the most important
things in life is about seeking novelty and always
putting yourself in new situations such that
you're laying down dense memories. The analogy
last thing I'll say on this is when you get to
the end of a childhood summer, it seems that
the summer lasted forever, and it's because
everything is new. So, you're writing stuff
down in your memory. But when you're older, you've
seen it all before, and you get to the end of the
summer and you think, "Wow. I can't believe it's
over already. I don't really remember it at all.
It seems as though the summer didn't last long."
Tim Ferriss: So, is it fair to then take from that
the key criterion for rich memory is novelty?
David Eagleman: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Doing new things?
David Eagleman: Exactly. And by the way,
this is one of the tiny silver linings to the
pandemic, which otherwise sucked. But the one
interesting part from the point of view of brain
plasticity was that it knocked all of us off our
hamster wheels, and we were finding that the world
wasn't what we expected. It was just unbelievable.
If we had talked in 2019 and said, "Hey, could
this ever happen?" We'd say, "That's a great
sci-fi story, but there's no way that it would
be that weird." But it was actually that weird,
and we all locked ourselves in our houses for
10,000 years. And so this is the kind of thing
when you go to the store and there's no
toilet paper there on the shelves, it takes
your internal model and it totally says, "Whoa,
I didn't even know that could happen." You start
thinking about supply chains. You start thinking
about how the world works. You're thinking about,
"Wait, is the barbershop going to be open?
Can I get a haircut during pandemic? Is this
coffee shop going to be open?" I mean, it just
forced us to think about the world completely
new. And I think if 2019 had continued and it had
just been the same old world, we'd actually be
less smart in a sense because our internal models
just would've never gotten challenged in that way.
Here's my idiothisis, which is an idiotic
hypothesis. I think that — I come up with
this a lot, but I think that we might actually see
a tiny decline in dementia some decades from now,
just because we had this opportunity in the middle
of our lives to actually restructure everything
and have to rethink everything going on.
Tim Ferriss: Did you say idiothisis?
David Eagleman: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So what other idiothises
do you have? Are there any that come to mind?
David Eagleman: Two a day at least. Yeah. Just
really, really stupid hypotheses that might just
be right, but they could just as well be wrong.
Maybe I would define an idiothisis as the kind
of hypothesis where I'm not really attached to
it enough to fight and die for it, but it's
interesting enough that I'm going to keep
an eye on it and see if I can collect data on it.
Tim Ferriss: I love this term, and I love the idea
of sharing some of them because I imagine that you
might come up with a lot of hypotheses that might
be, in some fashion, worth examining because
you're also not applying pressure to yourself
to identify all the scaffolding,
apply all the constraints and the
filters and so on. Okay. Idiothisis. I'm into it.
So, David, people can find you on eagleman.com,
certainly on social, David Eagleman on
most things, TikTok, Dr. David Eagleman,
and we'll link to everything in the show notes, so
books and so on. People can find your new podcast,
Inner Cosmos with David Eagleman. I imagine
wherever fine podcasts are to be found or is —
David Eagleman: Right, right.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. And you have
many books. I started with Sum. I think it's
a great book, but people can start anywhere.
Is there anything else that you would like
to mention, call attention to any formal
complaints you'd like to lodge publicly?
Anything at all that you would like to add
before we wind to a close for this conversation?
David Eagleman: I can't think of anything else.
That's great. I think we covered a lot of ground.
Tim Ferriss: All right. Sounds good. Well, David,
thank you so much for the time. And
to everybody listening as mentioned,
you can find links to everything in the
show notes as per usual at tim.blog/podcast.
And until next time, be just a little bit kinder
than is necessary to others and to yourself,
and keep experimenting. Experiment, experiment,
experiment. Explore, explore, explore. Novelty
folks, get after it. Thanks for tuning in.
David Eagleman: Great. Thanks.